outside the olympia shopping mall munich
is saying goodbye hundreds of mourners
still gather each day at the site of the
city's worst mass shooting paying silent
respect to the victims many bring tokens
of remembrance for the dead along with
thoughts for the injured photos from
social media are strewn among the
flowers keeping alive the memory of
those killed just a few meters away lies
the site where the gunman opened fire
killing nine and injuring dozens more in
incomprehensible act for many residents
new prezi imagine this of course it
affects you it could all be over just
like that
I'm the type of person who thinks life
is precious and they were so young
horrible it could have been me I like to
come here but now I'm here because it's
been a week and I want to pay my
respects to the victims it's scary when
you're on the street you are always
worried there are more police on the
streets they're normal after the string
of violent attacks that's shaken Bavaria
the state government has promised to
expand the police force but many people
here say that's not enough Munich is a
city unified in grief and while many
people find it difficult to express
their emotions in words others feel
compelled to talk to talk about their
friends and loved ones that they lost in
this senseless act of violence stanislav
Stannah is one of them he says he was
friends with some of the victims
my English have seen Kenny three nimesh
cancer I can't cry anymore I don't have
any more tears I've been crying
constantly standing here it hurts it's
like my heart is crying I don't know how
to describe it I have goose bumps
how can you get killed just like that
here's Austin Badon
a question that will haunt many here as
a city starts to heal